i think anish would love to see anything
oh kaya
result before it's a normal ish opening
for now
h4 if you're a cheapskate like that
twitter guy earlier you can look at it
for free no he's gone for a more
positional approach this is very
sensible yeah this is wardrobe we don't
want to see normal chests do we of the
fiance grinfeld oh i think that's what
peter svidler called it
in his chest of course and this white
queen coming out defending a pawn in the
center very logical stuff here i'm
surprised to see gary thinking this
bishop move by far the most normal the
most logical and okay magnus already
putting pressure on black center we call
this uh
kind of
half
the slav in a way because black's pawns
in the middle of the board on light
squares protect each other but now after
this trade
white has the most central board white
has a bit more space black has given up
a whole bunch of squares i try is this
the russian variation where you bring
the queen out i mean i remember there
was some games bottomneck um had this
couple times and some very important uh
competitions normal moves coming up here
both sides developing and it really is
about uh is white's center strong
minimal risk one plan for white for
magnus right now would be for example to
okay he drops his queen back first and
i'm expecting black's queen to come out
and maybe offer this trade and then one
idea for white is to move his rook
across in order to support a pawn push
and uh yeah here we go this is the
current position and instead of this
rook move white's bishop comes out
absolutely worth it we see a trade of
queens
and if as an amateur i've learned quite
a lot in the next in the lot in the six
months awesome courses and great
teachers just a superb i don't know i
think it clashes with this doesn't it
yeah
yeah but uh you know i actually got to
know and chat to john um
because we would have uh some coffee
together in jersey i love jersey by the
way yeah fantastic big deal because
jersey is a very small chess community
and to find
five women players
yeah chess will gonna uh are gonna help
the jersey team towards uh the olympiad
and i think many people are wondering if
you guys will play we have a bunch of
moves though
we do have a bunch of moves the queens
do uh the queens have left the board so
we're in kind of a middle game game
right now and white does have a bit of a
weird pawn structure
uh i'm still unsure whose position i'd
like here to be honest white has a bunch
of weak pawns especially on the b file
but white has a lot of space and a lot
of open lines so
we'll go into the plans maybe a bit
deeper in a moment all right i might be
there yeah
maybe yeah will you be there kyle
i will probably follow you guys from
here what do you think england's chances
are
do you want me to be really optimistic
or do you want me to be very english and
uh play down our chances i think they
have great chances guys
they really do yeah they're a strong
team yeah they do really well they work
really well as a team yeah and uh it's
going to be really exciting it's going
to be david gwain
they also have lucky jackets you go to
your weekend competitions and one way i
could always spot a chess player um like
let's say i got off the tube and i
wasn't sure where the venue was i just
look for the person carrying the plastic
bag because it'd always be the chess
player would always be that person with
his maybe shirt tucked outside their
jeans and carrying that plastic bag and
he's a chess player the evaluation bar
is really shifting towards black's favor
and
on the board i think i'm inclined to
agree i still don't think white's out of
it i think magnus has decent chances but
let's jump in to show what has changed
and uh it's all about the queen's coming
off first of all but it's all about
these pawns they are doubled they are
isolated they are weak they're
definitely targets but how can black get
at them black's safest but also best
movie played it wow wow
i got a positional idea right wow oh he
he mouse slipped on the next move oh but
this is also very logical no it's not
about sleep i mean i thought he'd push
it one one square but this also makes
sense right but opening the position is
risky when you've given up the bishop as
well so
bishop but instead aneesh says no he
wants to open things and after we see a
trade of pawns which is a okay
guaranteed to happen yes this pawn is
attacked but it can be easily defended
white just lifts up the rook now and
covers all the holes the problem is
these pawns they are weaknesses but you
can't really attack them anymore if you
drop your bishop back then white can
just remove one of the attackers of the
pawns for example bishop takes knight
and okay very very level position but
black here has an isolated pawn anish
definitely doesn't want that
he will have to maintain his form yeah
not just today but uh tomorrow as well
he gets bragging rights yeah and also
tie break advantages absolutely by
finishing top of the table but what
about the reverse
i think it's just bad etiquette i don't
know if it's any contractual obligations
but it's just those ideas can you or you
know straight away so i don't know it's
strange i don't know what the deal is
you know never been asked whether
secrets uh a part of it in terms of
which openings they can talk about which
openings they can discuss with others
but
um yeah it's at the very top level i
think it's a different game it's a lot
of cloak and dagger
it's like a spy novel
secrecy yeah i remember that game um
where i'm sorry yeah okay the rook is uh
centralized itself i remember that uh
opening idea that goufeld and i can't
remember who it was that he
he uh they concocted this fantastic idea
together
yeah i mean while on the board we have
seen a trade of one set of rooks a bit
of maneuvering nothing really has
changed the pawn structure is still
exactly the same
the trade of rooks has meant that black
occupies the d-file the open file but no
real entry squares or no effective entry
squares into the white camp white's king
meanwhile centralizing itself i think
magnus here he's getting ready for a
scenario where maybe the remaining set
of rooks get traded off and then white's
king is the quickest to the center uh
white's king might win the race and uh
is it is it possible for the black
knight to jump in
and give itself up
this is maybe what niche is thinking
about a bit of a flashy move the black
knight here sitting not really doing too
much at the moment and iranka wants to
jump it in to attack this bishop and it
looks like the black knight is under
threat but if the white rook moves and
captures this black knight then it loses
the protection of its own bishop and
black's rook can now capture the white
bishop and suddenly the
black rook creeps behind starts grabbing
some pawns this would be very good for
anish but i think the idea after the
knight jumped in which it has done is
that the rook doesn't move instead the
bishop retreats and now the bishop keeps
everything guarded and this has happened
the black knight now leaping back and
it's going to reposition itself
potentially
on this
eternal outpost where it can't get
kicked away not sure what it does there
really but uh it looks nice and pretty
and uh i'm pretty sure we'll see magnus
improve the king there we go and after
the black knight moves then at some
point we might see a trade of the
remaining ropes interesting move there
from a niche playing very quickly moving
uh the pawn by his king two squares
because you have to be very careful you
know moving pawns because you can't move
them backwards so it surprises me a
little bit uh maybe not a problem as
white doesn't have a knight to jump into
those holes created
um but yeah i mean it seems fairly even
still doesn't it this position very even
and it's kind of both sides have created
a barrier um with this pawn push black
not only has created a path in for his
king towards the center uh but he has
locked down on any white pawn pushes
this pawn can't push forward safely now
this square is covered twice
this pawn can't push safely now
this uh square is covered twice and same
for this pawn so it's very hard for
white to make progress he's dropped his
bishop back to one of my favorite
squares for this bishop um just because
it's nice and safe but it doesn't
actually do anything here the grizzchuck
square the gristrok square yeah why is
it called that i remember watching a
great game i got my you know i was
cheering it was david howe for the white
pieces against grizzchuk
and
david had a very good win by playing
this similar idea
in the iron man competition it's funny
in that tournament i won three games
with white by putting my bishop on this
square
ah interesting
i think it's just coincidence they
weren't necessarily great moves putting
the bishop here but it keeps the bishop
nice and safe for later and we might be
about to see uh i know whenever ivanka
makes that noise she thinks it's going
to be a draw uh we might be about to see
the white bishop
i have to watch out for if i play you
what was it again yeah let's go back to
the players we are about to see a result
the players are repeating the moves and
there we go abrupt but nothing to do the
players repeat aha so there's a draw
between the two top players so far in
the tournament